oh I welcome to this week's game life
after many long months of waiting III is
finally upon us and I've already gotten
the chance to check out a lot of the hot
new games on the show floor here are my
hands on impressions of five of the
biggest games of e3 coming in at number
five is dead space 3 that's right the
survival horror shooter game is back
with a big new twist drop in drop out
cooperative play now I like the e3 demo
for dead space but there was one thing
about it that kind of bothered me dead
space is supposed to be a creepy
slow-paced horror game so it was strange
to see the demo play more like Gears of
War my co-op partner was shouting f-this
and f-that as we took cover and fired
our machine guns who put this brotastic
shooter in my bed space hopefully the e3
demo isn't fully representative of the
final product coming in at number 4 is
capcom's radical reinvention of its
wintry shooter lost planet 3 instead of
blowing through aliens a hundred at a
time you spend a lot of this demo
getting in touch with the main
characters feelings as he sends video
messages back and forth with his wife
there's a lonely isolated feeling to the
whole thing as you stomp around the
mostly abandoned planet both on foot and
inside your giant mechanized rig which
you use later to attack a giant enemy
crab for massive damage
for our number 3 game we've got
something completely different the
unfinished Swan is an indie game for
playstation 3 that uses first person
shooter mechanics to accomplish
something very novel the world is
entirely colored white meaning you can't
see anything until you start shooting
globs of black paint which color in the
world and show you where to go a second
level has you shooting blobs of water in
order to cause things to grow and change
allowing you to keep moving the
unfinished Swan has an amazing sense of
wonder and discovery number two is
sleeping dogs from Square Enix if you're
into Grand Theft Auto you might want to
check out this open city game set in
Hong Kong you play an undercover cop
who's embedded in an organized crime
syndicate and you do all the things you
imagine like racing stolen cars getting
into martial arts fistfights and even
singing karaoke I got addicted to the e3
demo so I plan on clearing some time in
my schedule when the real thing is
released finally our number one game is
dishonored from Bethesda the best way to
describe this might be a first-person
Bioshock meets Assassin's Creed it's set
in a retro futuristic steampunk world
where your character can augment himself
with supernatural powers it's an
open-ended game you can either sneak
through using stealth or go in guns
blazing and kill everything you see just
because you have to neutralize an enemy
doesn't mean that you have to kill them
if you're smart enough to figure out a
way that's it for this week's game life
we will see you next week with even more
surprises from e3
you